[Music]
under what circumstances would you
not sleep with your husband not sleep
with him
like a regular just sleeping side next
to him like oh
sleeping liking you snoring smell yeah
snoring would be
in the shower for some reason you stink
so smells
yeah for sure we'll fight right why do
you why do you sleep
i'm already i'm smelling already what
you tell me to shower all the time
because i smell to you
uh your head is pretty crazy
your scalp is pretty wide so he doesn't
smell from the neck down
but from the head up it's like that
needs new
hair uh accessories well i mean
shampoos shampoos or gyms he needs to
wash his hair more often
so that's the reason why i tell you but
if you look at our pillowcases it's wild
because mine's like the color of the
pillowcase that it's supposed to be and
then his is like a huge grease
stain so that's why i always that's hair
product hair product
uh yeah yeah he does use hair product so
it's probably that
my sheets are like that too and i shower
before i go to bed
every night probably just sweat cause
that's what happens to bart he just
sweats
like in the middle and i think it's just
your body oils and your sweat just kind
of
soak into the i take two showers a day
on my side still darker than her side
it's probably like the dead skin rub in
and then yeah
like oil do you get kicked out of bed
for that or no my bed smells like i'm
gonna have to get it
what would be to get i'm trying to think
of times i've gotten
sleeped on the couch what did i do we've
never really slept apart like there's
not a reason they still fight and sleep
together
i mean we i mean yeah they'll fight over
the blankets
they have their own blankets oh yeah
they each have their own
we don't really fight and go to bed game
plan having separate blankets
yeah because i'm i might as really thick
it is really thin well this story
is about a man named
simon charlesworth i like that name what
a cool name
charles sounds a little regal the third
yeah
charles simon you know winston blackmore
because he's
look him up yeah look that guy up on jk
news he actually did an article about a
guy named winston
blackmore crazy [ __ ] all right anyways
this one's about simon charlesworth
and uh three years ago he
uh went to an induced coma for 10 days
and
due to uh complications with the flu
pneumonia
and sepsis what that means bio major
what is sepsis
i forgot is it an infection of the blood
or something
sounds like it yeah it's like an
infection of the blood
where it starts to like deteriorate your
own body how does she know what it is
bio major
oh cause i also study a little bit just
a tiny bit
for fun is everybody [ __ ] my major is
here you're not i thought that's
gonna tell you i didn't know about is
this the bio major podcast what's going
on
this is the bio book club man album club
is good bio
so he had a blood disease yeah where he
was
eating like he was it was like self
destroying his body basically right and
it spreads really fast and it spreads
really fast so then
uh he one day he was just showering and
he was like there's all the information
i'm smart dante okay
okay i'm not saying you're not i'm just
kidding but yeah so this guy woke up one
day
watch me be so wrong and decided to take
a shower just try and just you know
shake it off whatever
and he didn't make it out of his own
shower he collapsed he tore the
the shower curtain down psycho oh my god
you just gave me the movie scenes oh
[Laughter]
[ __ ] but in the [ __ ] shower but then
he got to a coma what happened
to a coma so then his wife comes home
from work later that day and finds him
and somehow he made it back
to the to the bed and he's on the bed
now blood ass naked with that with the
shower curtain the shower curtain over
his body
covering himself no simon west
charlesworth
simon all right you
crawled through the [ __ ] bed with
this shower curtain still in hand
it's dripping wet and he's oh he
actually funny thing he doesn't remember
anything he only has uh bits of memory
of his wife calling the ambulance
being lifted on a stretcher and
basically being told he needs to be
induced into a coma
that's like the old bits of memory
fragments of memory that he has like
basically all the traumatic memories he
he
remembers yeah did he remember what
happened in this coma no he didn't see
that's what always sucks because i feel
like you teleport into like
inception style and you have a whole
entire life there
and when you wake up or something yeah
it's like a movie
and then you wake up and then you don't
even remember what you just movied about
mm-hmm like your dreams you you do you
try to do it never remember
anesthesiologist and i'll just get my
molars out and i was like trying to like
think you know they're like count
because that's eight set of abc's with
me
i can't wait when they're like count i'm
like and i'm like i'm like trying to
think of like models or like something
fun to think about
and then i just woke up my bed in blood
you know why
inside the anesthesia there's an element
that gives you
amnesia so you forget so just in case
you actually wake up during surgery and
you
like experience something traumatic by
the time you actually wake up then you
forget about that
what if you delete good memories though
sounds like men in black what do you
mean they're giving you an
amnesia yeah inside the anesthesia
there's
a chemical in there that gives you like
slightly
temporary amnesia so just in case you
wake up you're like oh [ __ ]
my [ __ ] insides are outside of me ah
that's why they tape your eyes too when
you have surgery
ooh that's crazy don't wake up in
another surgery
man i wish i saw what they were doing
when they took out my
um wisdom teeth i could tell you the
[ __ ] deaths is [ __ ] going like
this
oh i felt it my neck was going like this
like that this guy's [ __ ]
did you wake up no i was awake they just
used novocaine yeah
i wish i was asleep though no they just
didn't wait what do you mean then what
do you want to see if you were awake no
i wanted to see a reflection like the
inside
because i i was trying to look you
wanted to vlog it i was trying to look
at yeah i was like oh what's going on
and then when i felt the liquids i'm
like that's blood dude
in my throat that's the worst okay my
doctor told me one time he was like oh
let me just spray you with a little bit
of water right
and and i was like okay cool but it was
like warm water so i was like
water's not warm it was like no it's
it's a lot thicker than
water too i think he was just being nice
not trying not to freak me out
it's [ __ ] blood and i could taste a
little bit too i was like nah
it's he's splattering blood all over i'm
more bothered by
um i'm more bothered by the liquid
choking feeling
than the surgery because you can't feel
the surgery but then it's hella
uncomfortable
because you're just like trying not to
swallow but then the position you're in
you're like
yeah no when they were taking out your
molars you didn't feel them like
breaking the
yeah i felt that and then like you could
feel it like all the way up to your
skull like this oh i can't feel that
crushing
not about that i'm not about that that's
why i wish i was asleep i was asleep
plus myself was compacted
so i was like kind of coming sideways
they had four at one time too much
i just uh have my teeth still from that
time if
people need to clone me they can use
that perfect that's good it's good to
know
all right so back to uh mr charlesworth
child's work yes uh so he went into a
coma
and when he woke up this is what he
saw all right so this is charles hi
charles
simon simon how long did he
was he comad for 10 days and so the
sepsis or whatever the [ __ ] happened to
his body
was taken over and they needed to
medicate him i forgot what the name of
the medication was
but this was the i'll i'll read it in a
little bit and let you guys know but
this is what happened when he woke up
that's gangrene right he has to lose his
toes yeah
that's that's that's aka frostbite
without him being in cold temperature
the blood left his toes like it just
left the toes and it just started is it
the hospital's fault
fingers too uh not fingers just toes
just toes he doesn't really
clip his toenails does he well this is
coma well
yeah comatose
that's good that's good hold on a second
they're done huh
yeah all right so he said um he can't
grow those back can he
he's turning into a white walker yeah so
quote at some point when i was in my
coma my blood pressure dropped and it
gave me medication to increase it
rapidly again
but in doing so it pushed blood towards
the organs
while starving the extremities so it was
a necessary evil it was necessary yeah
to keep him alive
uh and so when he woke up he had black
toes and the heels on his feet
uh all like layers of skin would just
fall off because it just didn't happen
of the the blood
to keep it circulating in those areas
fingers were peeling so it did affect
his hands
but not anything like long term like his
toes and his nose is also peeling too
like just like you just
started all the extremities too yeah
yeah
all that from a [ __ ] drop you gotta
give away your toes
give up your toes sepsis it was a
substance you know how he got
how do you get sepsis yeah they don't
cover watching it's like out of the blue
you're
still confused about the sepsis
situation but how do you get it
yeah google steps is really quick what
if he ate more spinach would that be
better no he'd just have big muscles
right
sepsis is a potentially life-threatening
condition that occurs when the body's
response to an infection damages its own
own tissues god damn it when the
infection fighting processes turn on the
body they cause organs to function
poorly and abnormally sepsis may
progress through septic shock that's
nothing to do with blood i was wrong
i'm not that smart it's zombie stuff
it's more your body turns on you you
start becoming a zombie
and it looks like zombie [ __ ] though
with the whole toes falling off so
the reason why i asked why the why if
wives in this room would not sleep with
their husbands is because the wife
during this time
refused to sleep with her [ __ ] up
so when he came home but he's stinky
let's hope so
i guess it smelled i mean it looks like
it would smell but he was uh
rubbing germline on his toes and i guess
jermaline's supposed it's like an
antiseptic to try and stop the
infections or whatever on the toes
um his toes would
eventually start falling off one
by one why would they just amputate this
[ __ ]
right they told them if they were gonna
act they told them huh
they were gonna amputate the entire foot
they
told him the whole foot i'd rather miss
a few toes
rather go above above and beyond
basically and just kind of
amputate the whole thing and this guy
was like nah i i
i i hike i do a lot out not anymore i'm
gonna do that [ __ ] no matter what so
i will live with my toes being black can
i get it it's gonna stink
until they fall off until they fall and
they would fall off one by one
and how many of you have left your smell
let me show you what happened
how many has left how many do you have
left i can't take any more of this story
does this penis have a black tip too
that's not bad
not too bad that's
i imagine this is what the other foot
looks like my dad's feet you still look
like that
i'll take that over no foot i'll take
that over me too me too
and then but i know toes take a big like
they play a huge role in
our walking is he able to walk yeah he
said it's more painful to walk now
and he doesn't have the same way but i
get special shoes yeah he said he used
to walk 13 miles no problem like he was
just like one of those kinds of guys
that
really enjoys walking and now he can't
do this no more and he says
just walking walking around his house is
enough it is enough for him with these
types of toes okay he's alive yeah
yeah i think he's equal you know when
you got the black toes you know when
you get you get like athlete's put you
got that little cortisol cream on your
foot at night you know but he got the
black toe
be like no babe don't worry about it
it's going to clear up soon charcoal
toes no that is good nasty toes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you